[Música]
bienvenidos a en 5 minutos donde
intentamos explicar de manera sencilla
asuntos complicados camiones iglesias y
viviendas quemadas cortes de carreteras
y una región militarizada en los últimos
días el presidente de chile el
progresista gabriel boric declaró un
estado de excepción acotado en el sur de
chile una medida que prometió no
utilizar cuando era opositor su gobierno
como el de todos sus antecesores
enfrenta el histórico conflicto mapuche
al que ningún gobierno antes ha logrado
dar una solución quiénes son los
mapuches que reclama a este pueblo
indígena y a qué se debe la violencia en
chile hay casi 2 millones de indígenas
mapuches es decir casi un 12 por ciento
de la población total su territorio
ancestral igual mapu se extiende por
parte de chile y argentina y en chile
comprende las regiones de bío bío y
araucanía este pueblo resistió
ferozmente la llegada de los colonos
españoles y no permitió que sus tierras
les fueran arrebatadas pero tras la
creación de chile como estado en él
siglo 19 muchos territorios fueron
ocupados de forma forzosa por el estado
en un proceso que se llamó la
pacificación de la araucanía
los mapuches nunca han dejado de
reclamar estas tierras y en la última
década sus pedidos se han intensificado
a falta de políticas que garanticen su
acceso a la tierra hoy en día inclusive
no son reconocidos de forma explícita
dentro de la constitución algo que se
busca cambiar con el actual proceso
constituyente que adelanta el país
consecuencia del estallido social de
2019 así la convención constituyente
pretende dar más representación a los
pueblos indígenas pero veamos por qué se
ha intensificado el conflicto y en qué
consiste la violencia durante décadas
grandes empresas agrícolas y forestales
se han asentado en la región los
indígenas denuncian afectaciones al
territorio por parte de la industria
maderera y ganadera entre otras y
rechazan lo que llaman un ecocidio que
los ha marginado
para hacernos una idea antes de la
colonización el territorio mapuche tenía
100 kilómetros cuadrados pero ya sólo
cuenta con el 5 por ciento de ellos tras
décadas de reclamos un sector del pueblo
mapuche se organizó e inició un llamado
a la autonomía del territorio
recurriendo a ataques a fábricas
camiones cortes de vidas y
enfrentamientos que han dejado indígenas
y militares muertos otros activistas han
optado por ocupar cargos en espacios
institucionales y muchos otros optan por
la protesta pacífica la respuesta del
gobierno a los ataques pero también a
otras manifestaciones ha sido de la
fuerza con dura represión y violencia
policial naciones unidas- ha llamado la
atención al gobierno chileno y alertado
de violaciones de derechos humanos
en 2021 el ex presidente sebastián
piñera decretó el estado de excepción y
señaló al principal grupo mapuche
organizado la coordinadora arauco
malleco cam de llevar a cabo acciones
terroristas este movimiento que defiende
la resistencia armada y se define como
autonomista ha llevado a cabo las
acciones violentas esta rama del
activismo asegura que sus actos son de
resistencia ante una violencia
estructural estos activistas y otros de
tipo pacífico denuncian que el gobierno
ignora del convenio 169 de la
organización internacional del trabajo
que está inscrita a las naciones unidas'
este establece que es un deber del
estado respetar a la cultura y tradición
de los pueblos indígenas también
determina que los países deben reconocer
el derecho de propiedad sobre las
tierras que tradicionalmente han ocupado
la normativa aprobada por el congreso en
2009 forma parte de la legislación del
país la región se ha convertido en la
más pobre de la nación algo a lo que las
autoridades locales atribuyen a la poca
inversión extranjera por falta de
seguridad mientras la pobreza se ha
vuelto también causa de más violencia es
decir un pez que se muerde la cola en
los últimos tiempos la violencia se ha
recrudecido con presencia de bandas
criminales a falta de la presencia del
estado incluso la propia ministra del
interior es que a sitges fuere y vida
hace poco con disparos al aire en una
visita a la región para entablar el
diálogo ahora las fuerzas armadas
vuelven a custodiar parte de este
territorio un giro drástico en el
discurso de boris que durante meses
criticó a su antecesor o por una
política similar en medio de un aumento
de su desaprobación y de presión del
gremio de los camioneros y de una buena
parte de la sociedad por garantizará
mayor seguridad moriche recién
posesionado a principios de marzo
resolvió imponer el llamado estado de
excepción acotado este en la práctica
permite al ejército custodiar las vías
de la región pero no le otorga la
posibilidad de controlar personas como
sí sucedió durante el gobierno de piñera
se trata de una medida sin embargo
controversial que ha provocado llamados
a la resistencia boris y promete
impulsar el diálogo una vía a la que
algunos grupos mapuches se muestran
contrarios también ha acelerado un
paquete de medidas para hacer frente al
conflicto como la creación de un
ministerio de pueblos indígenas o la
entrega de más recursos para avanzar en
la devolución de tierras faltará ver si
su apuesta ha logrado un conflicto
centenario
si les sirvió el vídeo para entender el
origen del conflicto mapuche y sus
desafíos los esperamos en otro episodio
de cinco minutos en france 24 y france24
puntocom